proteste gegen die korona diktatur in
berlin leipzig und anderswo gehen
wütende menschen auf die strassen
fürchten um ihre freiheit
aber stimmt es sind masken und
kontaktverbot wirklich der beginn eines
neuen zwangs regimes das uns mit corona
notverordnungen regiert bild sprach mit
einer der letzten zeitzeuginnen die
diktatur und weltkrieg noch selbst
erlebt haben was waren ihre gedanken als
die korona krise begangen es hat mich
schon an den kriegs erste kriegszeit
also an den beginn des zweiten
weltkrieges erinnert als dieses carola
plötzlich hier bei uns einfach da ist
mir ziemlich früh klar geworden mein
gott das erinnert sich dass kinder
menschen sind die sich da im zaum halten
sondern das ist ein virus damals was du
denn da drückt man sich nicht dagegen
wehren und man konnte auch nicht sagen
ich will meine freiheit haben das war
mit dem ersten tag des krieges wurde
auch einen nutzen lassen
und die war geduldet dieses deutet kein
widerspruch oder überhaupt keine
aufbegehren und halle war die waren die
soldaten waren berechtigt standrechtlich
zu erschießen
ich heiße herz in zelten bei 1926
geboren also jetzt 94 jahre alt für den
groß geworden und zwar in der syker
straße 3 das ist kurz vor der bernauer
straße da wo die versöhnungskirche ist
gerade alte menschen sind anfällig für
corona infektionen tausende sterben
helga cent feldern ist seit jahren
erblindet hat sie angst ich habe keine
angst ich hab auch keine aus folge virus
ich versuche das was man mir dreht oder
auch jetzt nicht so zu fühlen denn es
ist nützlich und notwendig aber das
mache ich auch weil ich weiß dass das
helfen bis jetzt ist mir heute nicht
sprechen
das hätte auch anders kommen können denn
helga schon früh ganz andere epidemien
überlegt als ich kind war muss sich
sämtliche kinderkrankheiten durch sehen
es die freunde von mir und rum sind
einen kinderlähmung gestorben oder krank
geworden
das war und dabei man konnte von glück
sprechen wenn man selber davon verschont
blieb die kinder treffen die wir
bekommen haben
die haben immer na ja so verliert man
daran zu tun hat ich hatte schwere
schauer
ich hatte schwer mal sein ich hatte sie
zucken mumps röteln außer kinderlähmung
und diphtherie dass davon bin ich
glücklicherweise verschont geblieben
das hat sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht
überrascht als der krieg ausbrach war
helga 15 jahre alt
für sie die furchtbarste erinnerung im
leben da kriegt war das schlimmste was
einem passieren konnte denn weil wir ja
nicht wo der hinführt und und was was
weiter wird es wurde geschossen das war
schlimm wir konnten nicht auf die straße
sowieso ist sowieso nicht meine
verpasste sehr auf dass ich über
geschützt bin das war schon ein hartes
leben damals und überhaupt nicht mit
heute zu vergleichen
und wenn die jungen leute meinen sie
würden um ihre freiheit gebracht dann
hätten sie da keine guten karten gesetz
zeit gehabt und wir haben beständig uns
wir haben ständig was anderes tun wirst
du unter anderem abschied nehmen von
vielen menschen von jungen menschen von
älteren von von seiner habe von dem was
man sich erarbeitet hat dass das war
alles weg
1943 das fünfte kriegsjahr bombenhagel
auf berlin
auch die familie von helga cent feldern
blieb vom bombenkrieg nicht verschont
ihr haus in der huttenstraße im berliner
wedding ein raub der flammen
das haus selbst war nicht betroffen aber
das nebenhaus und da wir wussten dass
die häuser gehörten beide zusammen und
da waren wohl auch kein teilweise die
breitband durchbrochen
da wussten wir dass das haus nicht
stehen bleiben und das war dann ja auch
so und es gab ja keine möglichkeit zu
löschen
als ich dann von der vor dem haus stand
da war es dann soweit dass es brennt so
unser brannte sind unser stuck an der
decke unter dieser strecke stand dann
mein schönes klavier nicht und das ging
dann auf dem baugrund zu sein wusste ich
das ist alles vorbei und da habe ich den
neuen kleinen na ja so ein klein
weihnachtsfeier creatures entfelden
überlebte so wie auch ihre eltern sie
arbeitete später als lehrerin lebt seit
dem krieg im berliner kiez um den
lutherplatz nicht weit vom ku'damm und
potsdamer platz
die sie teils als trümmerfrau selbst
wieder aufbaut heute über 75 jahre
später corona stimmen die vergleiche mit
hitlers winterthur zu den
notverordnungen der nazizeit
das ist einfach eine empfehlung sich da
sein leben zu retten
aber das ist nun mal so bei solchen
ausfällen im leben ist das so nach sehen
wir eigentlich jetzt jahrzehnte eine
verfügungs gesellschaft halten eine
spaßgesellschaft und das ist vorbei wir
müssen jetzt mal wieder beschreiten und
sehen dass wir ins normale leben kommen
dass gar nicht so einfach ist
und wie reagiert die politik heute was
hält eine 94 jährige vom angeblich so
strengen coroner regime der
bundesregierung und gibt ihnen
ratschläge
es wird keine befehle geben wo habe ich
ich habe noch kein bisher gehört zum
erbe das macht sie nicht sie waren es 1
da sollte man doch mal akzeptieren und
beim ein bisschen dahin zu erhöhen
ob das denn auch stimmen könnte denn
wenn man in die vergangenheit geguckt da
war's das schon etwas anders also sehr
viel anders aus es ist überhaupt kein
vergleich mit den zwölf jahren brechen
aber die jungen leute haben natürlich
ist klar die haben pele geduld und
kennen ja auch nichts anderes schon seit
generationen nicht
und die wissen auch nicht was wirklich
wenn es denn mal ernst so etwas
ernsthaft leben sein könnte
und das haben wir leider zu viel
erfahren dabei zehn zwölf jahren
die zeit war so kurz und die hat uns so
viel unglück gebracht was ganz europa
nicht aufarbeiten kann
[Musik]
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren